so it may come as a bit of a surprise to
those of you who know me in this podcast
I am NOT the most sentimental human
being I once forgot my own birthday my
dad though he's a total SAP
yeah he's manly and he's my hero but
he's a SAP he cried at the end of
terminator yes really terminator my mom
has always said that if the house is on
fire or under water or following into
the San Andreas Fault
my dad would probably be inside the
house trying to save every box of family
photos and every film he could find now
we have legacy box we don't have to
worry about my dad burning or drowning
or falling into the abyss with an armful
of boxes trying to save all the family
memories it couldn't be easier you just
send your old pictures films video tapes
to legacy box they put them on a DVD or
a thumb drive and that saves them
forever makes it convenient they're
preserved they're ready to watch them
ready to reshare and relive if you're
sentimental which I'm not mostly legacy
box comm slash Ben make sure you do that
you get that 40 percent discount on your
order